[Music]  there's a returning queen this season we  find out in the first episode you give  us any hints on who that might be  well you know we love to do a twist in  our show and there is a returning queen  someone who I felt it needed another  chance we've done this before we brought  back shangela before hi  [Music]  we brought back other Queens who I felt  you know what I think that she deserves  another chance I'm not going to say the  name but I will say that uh it was an  important choice and it was a choice  that I'm really happy with your decision  that person didn't come back an audition  again you reach that stem or yeah God in  this case I knew the girl very well girl  was a you notice uh and I didn't have to  audition again I thought you know what I  she need she needs to be seen more  you